zurück an diesem freitag eine freitag
dem dreizehnten freitag der dreizehnte
für den womöglich ein blutbad geplant
war in essen dass hier das könnte
nämlich die ankündigung dazu seine
botschaft geschmiert an eine wand auf
einer mädchentoilette lesen sie mal da
steht kennst du freitag dem 13 blutbad
am 13.5 mfg mit freundlichen grüßen don
bosco don bosco das ist dieses gymnasium
in essen wo ein 16 jähriger ein massaker
anrichten wollte und wir fragen uns
jetzt ist das hier die ankündigung
seiner tat auf eine mädchentoilette mehr
dazu wissen gleich unsere reporter
hierbei bild live aber noch einmal der
fall es geht um den 16 jährigen der vor
24 stunden in essen durch einen sek im
schlaf ganz früh morgens überwältigt
worden ist ein teenie der offenbar einen
anschlag geplant hat mit einem
waffenarsenal bomben armbrüste schwerter
all das hat die polizei bei diesem typen
sichergestellt ein junge der zu hause
rechtsextreme sinn aufgeschrieben hat
und der eben jetzt in diesem haus
offenbar wohnte ja ein blutbad anrichten
wollte terror von einem erst 16-jährigen
geplant
zugriff in essen in nordrhein-westfalen
zugriff in letzter sekunde
die polizei essen vereitelt am
donnerstagmorgen einen geplanten
terroranschlag auf eine schule
meine damen und herren
möglicherweise hat die nrw polizei heute
ein alptraum verhindert nachdem die
polizei vor einem möglichen amoklauf
eines schülers gewarnt wird stürmt das
sek um 24 eine dachgeschosswohnung in
essen borbeck
es ist das zu hause einen 16 jährigen
jugendlichen erst schüler am don bosco
gymnasium der mutmaßliche ort des
geplanten blutbads die einsatzkräfte
überwältigen den jugendlichen im schlaf
in seinem zimmer finden sie 16 selbst
gebaute rohrbomben darunter auch einen
nagel bombe waffen sogar mehrere
armbrüste währenddessen regeln ermittler
die aktuelle und ehemalige schule des 16
jährigen schülers ab die polizei setzt
spürende ein durchkämmt jedes
klassenzimmer nach bereits deponierten
sprengkörpern
das motiv verstörend die ermittler
finden ein notizbuch des 16 jährigen
schülers vollgeschrieben mit
ausländerfeindlichen und antisemitische
schriften sogar eine todesliste ist
dabei sein eigenes
rechtsextremes manifest das geplante
blutbad kaum vorstellbar es liegt eine
klare politische motivation vor es ist
kein amoklauf insofern er in einem
milieu wenn auch für sich alleine
zunächst so weit wir wissen
sich vorbereitet hat planvoll ein
solches mordattentat es geschehen zu
verüben wer kann womöglich auch und die
situation das ist eine gewisse nachname
funktion hat nachdem dies mehrfach ja
passiert es in deutschland
die generalstaatsanwaltschaft ermittelt
jetzt wegen terrorverdachts gegen den 16
jährigen schüler
ja und jetzt also diese botschaft
gefunden auf einer schultoilette eine
mädchentoilette dort den ersten an
diesem sportback gymnasium auf dass
dieser 16 jährige früher gegangen ist
kennst du freitag den 13 blutbad am 13
05 mfg mit freundlichen grüßen don bosco
wir schalten zu unserem bild
chefreporter frank schneider der diesen
fall recherchiert mit dem wir in den
letzten 24 stunden immer wieder neue
hintergründe erfahren haben über diese
schreckliche tat frank erklär uns jetzt
einmal diese botschaft was wisst ihr im
moment gibt es einen zusammenhang zu
dieser geplanten tat des 16 jährigen
die polizei vermutet natürlich einen
zusammenhang weil es wäre schon sehr
ungewöhnlich der in dieser schriftzug
soll laut schülern erst am mittwoch also
einen tag vor der festnahme des
verdächtigen aufgetaucht seien
möglicherweise ist das auch ein grund
gewesen warum ein mitschüler sich dann
doch irgendwann dann nötig sagt zur
polizei zu gehen er ist im blut rot
geschrieben er spricht genau darauf
freitag den 13 an und die polizei geht
ja auch davon aus dass das
möglicherweise der tatzeitpunkt gewesen
wäre man sprach gestern immer von
zeitnah sei das geplant gewesen die
bombe war noch nicht endgültig fertig
aber wohl relativ schnell
fertigzustellen gewesen also es würde
schon sehr sehr gut zusammen passen die
polizei gestern spuren der sich hat auf
dieser mädchentoilette hat natürlich
auch fingerspuren genommen weil das der
täter unbedingt handschuhe tragen hat
wenn er diesen schriftzug angebracht hat
wäre vielleicht eher ungewöhnlich
insbesondere weil das ist ja die
vermutung der ermittler er bei der tat
sich selber auch töten wollte
beziehungsweise ich töten lassen wollte
durch möglicherweise eingreifende
polizeibeamte und es kann natürlich auch
ein stück weit ein hilfeschrei gewesen
sein des täters immer wieder erhöhen wir
uns sehen wir dass täter vor solchen
taten
auch immer signale senden immer hinweise
geben sich jemand doch irgendwie
anvertrauen dinge andeuten und das
könnte hier auch der fall gewesen sein
ja aber in der tat das klingt ja nach
einem eingreifen ja in fast letzter
minute also 24 stunden gut 24 stunden
ist es her dass das sek dort ausgerückt
war und die botschaft liegt eben nahe
wie das gesagt dass das die tat für
heute tatsächlich geplant war für diesen
freitag den 13 frank du hast mit all
deinen kollegen recherchiert in diesem
fall was wisst ihr mittlerweile über
diesen rechtsextremen hintergrund dieses
jungen mannes ja dieses team ist diese
16-jährigen
ja die ermittler sagen ganz klar es gibt
dieses ringbuch man sprach er immer von
manifest aber es ist ein ringbuch indem
er eben seine seine gedanken
aufgeschrieben hat die sind massiv
ausländerfeind nicht massiv
antisemitisch er hat halt großen haus
auf farbige einen großen hass auf juden
ehrt hakenkreuze dort rein gemalt er hat
ss runen dort ein gemalt als ist schon
sehr sehr eindeutig auf der anderen
seite ist wohl in diesem ringbuch auch
sehr viel ich nenne es mal verzweiflung
drin suizidgedanken auch eine art
abschiedsbrief also ich glaube es ist
eine mischung aus einem verzweifelten
schüler was aber keiner vermutet hat die
anderen schüler in seinem umfeld sagen
alle er war zwar in dem sinne nicht
integriert er hatte kein durch den
freundeskreis aber er war auch überhaupt
gar kein außenseiter er war überall
akzeptiert
das ist gerade es ist im moment ganz
schwierig das motiv tatsächlich klar zu
benennen und trotzdem die
generalstaatsanwaltschaft hat ja die
ermittlungen in diesem fall auch
übernommen das heißt es geht hier um
terror viele waren gestern ganz
vorsichtig das als solches auch zu
benennen nennst du es nach dem was ihr
bisher wirst terror
na ja sonst hätte die
generalstaatsanwaltschaft diese
zentralstelle für terror eben nicht
übernommen es hat nicht die
bundesanwaltschaft übernommen die eben
für große terroranschläge verantwortlich
ist ich sage mal es ist so auf der ebene
dazwischen aber es ist natürlich ein
star der verdacht weil wenn man dieses
ringbuch findet man muss das ja auch
ernst nehmen muss ja auch erst noch mal
prüfen gibt es nicht doch möglicherweise
anstifter hintermänner auch irgendwo
vielleicht im netz irgendwelche
komplizen irgendwelchen leuten die ihn
angestiftet haben das muss man jetzt im
einzelnen entleeren genauso wie jetzt in
diesem moment geprüft wird ob und wann
er heute dem haftrichter vorgeführt wird
es steht auch immer noch im raum dass er
möglicherweise auch in der psychiatrie
untergebracht wird das muss man jetzt
abwarten das wird sich wahrscheinlich
heute mit erklären man muss natürlich
noch mal dazu sagen wir haben den
beitrag gehört es gibt da noch eine
todesliste und das ist auch so absurd da
ist ein muslimischer schüler bei mit dem
er gestern noch eigentlich ein referat
vorbereiten wollte mit dem er eigentlich
einen guten kontakt hatte der steht auf
dieser liste stehen auch lehrer auf der
liste stehen aber auch ganz normale
deutsche schüler auf der liste also so
richtig weiß man nicht was seine
motivlage war aber durch dieses ringbuch
durch diese klaren antisemitischen und
ausländerfeindlichen hassbotschaften und
auch die symbole wie hakenkreuze und ss
und muss es natürlich total ernst
genommen werden dieser rechtsextreme
hintergrund dann kann unser bild
chefreporter frank schneider danke für
eure recherche dort in essen direkt vor
ort mit all deinen kollegen zu diesem
schrecklichen fall diesen geplanten
terror dort in essen durch einen 16
jährigen jetzt aufgetaucht eine geheime
botschaft geschmiert an eine toiletten
waren dort an der bergschule in essen
möglicherweise die ankündigung für
dieses blutbad für heute für diesen
freitag den 13